yeah welcome a new video and it's a
five-minute chess on a sec let's see I'm
what opening I'm getting a plane default
the groom felt on yeah the groom fat so
pure what line to play came let's go for
this side line which is some quite
interesting the intention is to take
with the bishop on c3 buddy
involuntarily retreats so on I need to
to cover d4 and I think I play push-up
g5 going to cover the porn okay yeah
probably 2h for getting some or
maintaining some pressure along the age
48 diagonal so that you cannot easily
play a five now what I'd like to do is
to just turn continue developing with e3
Roxy one Bishop e2 normal moves and
clean the ideal scenario would be that
he won't come get in c5 Andy five this
is also why I would only play III I mean
now default was just hanging but what's
intention is not to build up a big
center with e4 because this is just too
vulnerable here likes them too much
pressure on the center so just III and
now be should be two castles whoopsie
196 of course a tech deform therefore I
needed to react with III but as
mentioned i wanted to play this move
from anyway so I'm the knight on c6
doesn't exactly help with playing c5 for
taking the center so i think this is
rather i'm rather normal
I think black should just cancel now
yeah or maybe this move suddenly also
possible yeah just mean just Bishop you
two should be the the best square for
this piece yeah one idea for black young
is some castles and then exactly move
the Queen and then go 45 but some 45
only five i might play d 5 it's a
possibility not shown yeah let's just
cancel short i mean the sun i cannot
play without this move anyway so castle
yeah if I phone the normal response yeah
d 5 e 5 d 5 i'm thinking about the
should be five yellow okay t5 green
looks som like the normal response
anyway so let's not spend too much time
i also on can consider am night xe5 it's
a tactic that needs to be calculated
Bishop takes if i push of g4s simple
just winning upon and 95 Bishop e2 97
some could be good for white it should
be 297 the abruptly one rupee one
King takes our piece down right so this
is so not working 95 Bishop e2 97 Bishop
takes d1 well that takes me six I can
play okay seems to work just gaining the
spawn I mean this should be five was at
the bad move this is so why I thought
twice about that there should be 5c 6066
it's just a slightly better for wide but
95 now looks like i'm just a pawn yeah
but should be too i'm not quite sure
what he is thinking about we should be
five Bishop g4 is just disastrous you
can play a five but that's not not good
now I have this this move attacking also
the rook so after recapture I can get
you one if I take with the rook the a
rook yeah one okay Africans better
anyway what I was getting at is that he
would even get my porn on a 2k not have
5 mm yeah okay need to need to retreat
so on I am again I got this pawn but
then of course he's got a very strong
bishop on g7 so on it's not hmm it's not
one hundred percent clear that this is
some just an extra porn okay he takes
yeah well okay I'm I've got them rather
weak pawn structure now so
um this was certainly an option for him
ok let's try to open up the position
quickly 11 point is he hasn't cashed out
yet so can try to UM get them at these
these pawns quickly jump this wasn't the
best problem ok well I'll get an extra
porn at the end but it's not enough to
win ok there's nothing better I it
wasn't easy anyway that the pawn is nice
but the bishop is very strong and taking
on c3 not sure if this was the best for
black but some this kind of position is
certainly am NOT very promising for
white I'll play g4 to get some to gain
some space and make sure that h5 now now
it prepares h5 now what I was getting at
is that it's a good thing if I would if
I can prevent this move I try to do that
on age of five play g5 of course I'm
weakening the second rank so maybe you
can play rook a two or something but
yeah
then my attention is rookie 55 and now
try to get the King to f3 of course it's
a draw but four against three you can
always um try for a bit and try to to
gain some some little things and some
hmm it's really not not very promising
I'm cats not much not much you can try
well okay g60 can take even on at five
yeah i was a bit bit slow week he could
have even tried to play this nonsense on
time yeah it's just them a four against
three is simply simply a draw you cannot
do much and again maybe i was i'm a bit
too quick and playing this this d6 thing
yeah i also i must admit it i forgot
that he can take so it can take on c3
immediately I only thought about seat XD
656 oh I should probably a play as he
form so yeah it's not easy anyway can go
kicking the seven for example and then
rook h2h and always get counter play
against a and C porn it's not not easy
at all
yeah the computer also doesn't give
white much now okay what I did is um
yeah leading through this four against
three but this this is simply no
advantage I mean I managed to get G
fallen but you you really cannot make
any progress yeah thanks for watching